this is star talk
is kaya now they're just making their
stuff
neal they're just throwing with me now
man
they're making up names where's dietrich
from uh dietrich is
uh just coming to us from earth from
earth okay and
once again here's a question hello dr
tyson what's the deal with thor's hammer
okay so here's the deal all right i'm
watching thor the movie
right all right now i don't cl i don't
go back to the like earliest comic book
so
don't i don't count myself as a comic
book expert but i do enjoy some good
movies about
superheroes so i'm watching this the
thor movie okay right
the the first of the the movies and
there's a scene
where one of the characters describes
the hammer
as being forged in the ashes of a dying
star
wow and i said yes
i can calculate this now there are many
different kinds of dying stars right but
the thor's hammer is very heavy
and only thor can pick it up right so
let me go to the kind of dying star
that's really heavy okay and that would
be a neutron star
right which is made of dense pack
neutrons so i said well how big is
thor's hammer
so a friend of mine who has a replica of
gave it to me and i measured the size of
the hammer
and i said okay if we make a hammer out
of
neutron star matter okay i can calculate
how much that would weigh
awesome it would weigh as much as a herd
of three billion elephants
wow three billion plus or minus i have
to i tweeted this i would go back and
check my tweet
but it's a number about it might have
been 30 billion but it's
it's heavy right and then i realized
that's why even
the hulk couldn't pick it up right
because what there's nothing the hulk
can't do
can't pick this up because it weighs as
much as a herd
of three billion elephants okay and
again the exact number is in my tweet
um you go back like a few months it's
there like a year it's there
all right so i so i tweeted that and i
said
and i have a picture of my hand holding
the yeah
right and i said thor lent me his hammer
to do some experiments and
at its current density forged in this in
the out of the ashes of a dying star
bada bang here's how much it weighs and
people say oh my gosh mind blown oh my
god that is pretty mind blowing
so no watch wait then a couple months
later
someone comes in and says i
am an expert on thor and norse legends
and you did not do the right calculation
really and i said
what and he said so this person is a
professor of physics
okay and norse god specialist
wow okay he gets laid a lot okay
so i so i got nothing on him there
i got all i do to see the damn movie all
right okay he's a
norse god special forgive me i forgot
his name but he's out there
and he came back and said no you didn't
do the it's made of some
ethereal stuff and he made some estimate
about how much the density and how much
he would weigh
and the thor's hammer would weigh about
six pounds
and i said no that ain't right no i like
my answer better even if it's wrong
yeah yeah i was gonna say that does not
sound cool
weighs about six pounds but i suppose
that what he's saying is because he's a
god
and they're you have to be worthy only
the person worthy to rule
asgard can lift the but my wrong answer
was way cooler yeah it is way cool
because six pounds how much does thor's
hammer weigh
six pounds that sucks right right
exactly that's that's a sucker
i i conceded i had i and i said thank
you
but still yeah neutron dying neutron
star
that's cool yeah a neutron star is the
remnant of a star that has just exploded
as a supernova
right so there's the ashes of a dying
star for you that's yeah but he was
saying it's some it's some mythical
substance that it's made right then six
pounds all right
that's the end whatever some other again
the right numbers are in the tweet
because i'm not doing calculations in
front of you right now but when i did
the tweet i did the calculation
yeah cause you got me on the spot here i
don't know well who knew that dietrich
uh will come up with a super cool
question so simply put what's up with
the well because there's a whole story
behind there's a back story
my calculation i was shown to be wrong
and it was by a physicist
norse expert yeah exactly yeah what does
he know
spend all that time studying norse gods
please
all right thanks for ruining dr north
god
this is star talk